new summer movie trailers are out and
I'm gonna talk about it first up
transformers the dark of the Moon
alright so after the second Transformers
movie might default stands for all
things Transformers in terms of movies
is skepticism because Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen was the movie it
was that one thing that made me go I did
not like that movie at all in fact I'm
gonna get on camera and rant about it to
the world
yes transformers 2 is the genesis of all
you see here so in terms of the third
movie skeptical but as for the trailer
it's ok it's like two and a half minutes
long it feels like seven it shows Neil
Armstrong and company tromping on the
moon on the Dark Side of the Moon where
they find not a Pink Floyd concert but a
ship which is really funny because I
would think when agent moustache was
breaking it down for the crew in the
first movie he would have at least
mentioned that Armstrong found a
transformer ship on the moon
I had trumped that whole Mars story but
like I said two and a half minutes long
and it showed us much just like teasers
that are 30 seconds long show so we'll
see how it goes
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides Captain Jack is back and he's here
to prove to the world that Disney can
still milk as zillion and a half dollars
out of this franchise they should be
captaining this one all right so when we
all heard that they were making another
Pirates of the Caribbean movie we all
thought the same thing
hash crab I saw this trailer with no
expectations whatsoever it should have
sucked I actually enjoyed it weird I
know a fourth movie looking good the
movie shows a couple of familiar faces
like Barbosa and Gibbs but I'm glad they
didn't think of some convoluted reason
to bring back Legolas and Domino Harvey
and I am kind of worried that Jack
Sparrow's one-liners are gonna feel
forced again
is that it I think so like in the first
movie he was the cool supporting
character he wasn't the main spotlight
the things he said were clever cuz they
were built off things that other people
said or things that other people did
then in the second the third movies that
were like okay we got him to have more
Jack Sparrow wisdoms it's got to be more
Jack Jack attack and it just fell for us
because every line was weird it's okay
for him to be weird because Jack Sparrow
is weird but it was just overboard with
lines like mop a knight and with
something he calls a heart a thump thump
did he become [ __ ] ian mcshane is
gonna kill his black beard though he
looks badass
it looks like that abusive uncle that
you don't want to have you kind of do
like Ganondorf from Smash Brothers yeah
that shit's bad news so the Pirates
trailer pretty cool dawn alright so
other than the fact that Thor is the
fetish of an eight-year-old kid on
adventures and babysitting I have known
nothing about Thor but he is a God and
in the world of Marvel big-screen
crossovers bringing a God into the mix
probably a little tough and Kenneth
Branagh was asked actually you pronounce
his name Brian er I didn't know that but
it's called Branagh
it's pronounced Brenner yeah you know he
was asked like he do Shakespearean stuff
in plays and did why why comic books
that's weird he explained it that it's
all the same stuff family rivalries love
conflict same Shakespearean stuff that
he's always done just different coat of
paint so after that it made sense but
I'm not gonna lie of these three
trailers this was my favorite I mean it
looks surprisingly good I didn't think
it was gonna look good but it does I
mean George Kirk looks like Thor Anthony
Hopkins is Odin and who doesn't love it
when you're taking on a group of hard
enemies and Odin just jumps in there and
slices them all in half a [ __ ] wrong
thing you got Natalie Portman as hot
love interest girl God's at war and it
looks good the costumes look a bit
costumey but they look a hundred times
better than the pieces of [ __ ] in Clash
of the Titans so I'm not really gonna
complain about it they're gods whatever
bring on the weird costumes Thor's
costume looks badass he looks like a
badass like this shot right here boom
badass and that weird Cyclops laser face
robot in the trailer looks a bit like
that big robot from The Day the Earth
Stood Still other than that it looks
like a really cool movie about a fallen
God trying to save his world and ours
his fate is in his own hand
No oh god that was cast out because he
said to Odin fool no one ever says words
like that anymore I want to hear the
word fool put in a sense like a real
sentence in real life I want to see two
people arguing and just have someone go
oh I'd be like that guy wins and Anthony
Hopkins growls
weird I'm not gonna lie if he growled at
me I'd be like and then I get cast down
with Natalie Portman please open your
eyes
but all these trailers are just teasers
we know nothing about the movies yet but
this summer might just be better than
the last two I'll put the links of the
trailers below check them out comment
below let me know what you think and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more then click
right here to see more